hope this game doesn't like try to do
the whole tragedy by the comedy thing
and that's where you [ __ ] up
[Music]
I've been getting requests to review
this game for about two years and I
wasn't quite sure if I was ready for it
until now the funny thing is while I've
been typecast as the spider-man guy on
the Internet people in my personal life
know me as the Deadpool guy every other
article of clothing I own is black and
red I have that symbol on just about
everything I own and people at my high
school sometimes don't even bother
learning my name it just refer to me as
Deadpool this character is very special
to me and when the game was announced I
was beyond excited in the four years
since it's come out this game has built
up a kind of legacy that I'd like to
talk about today in addition to the
usual review stuff so imagine this as a
retrospective of the Deadpool game all
one of them in the four years since it
came out I think I finally realized
something weird this game nearly ruined
Deadpool we were worried okay hear me
out
alright I think by the end of this
you'll agree with me just give me a
chance now before I get into that and
talk about the real problem at the heart
of this game let's chat about the parts
I like that being pretty much all of the
gameplay Deadpool is an eccentric
character to say the least and he's a
bit eclectic when it comes to methods of
ultraviolence but he's always got a
brutal solution in mind whenever he
encounters a problem this game captures
deadpool fighting ability pretty well
between all the different kinds of guns
the three different melee weapons and
the goddamn bear traps you can throw
this combat feels pretty close to what
it looks like when Deadpool fights in
the comics so good on them especially
like that if you hit the trigger while
melee fighting he'll start doing gun
kata in the game looks like a monty oum
fight scene this isn't one of those
games where the upgrade tree feels
tacked on and useless the upgrades make
a huge difference you start to feel
really powerful after you have all the
improvements for your ammo capacity and
health because you're dishing out
bullets like crazy and soaking up just
as many like a red and black sponge I'm
low on power but rich in vitamin C low
on energy but full of vitamin C
if I had any complaints that they took
the dodge counter button from the Arkham
series and they didn't quite do it right
it has the same problem as the amazing
spider-man 2 where the margin of error
on the counter is so wide that it
doesn't really matter how early or late
you hit the button as long as you hit
the button and on the occasions that you
aren't close enough to counter the
generic enemies you'll just teleport
that's a bit over power to just hit a
button and become invincible for a few
frames plus he hasn't add that
teleporter belt thing since like 1999 he
ditched it because and I quote it made
things too easy well I guess all the
game did was just confirm that another
thing that I think could have been
nerfed is the auto aim if you hit the
aim button on one of your long-range
weapons and the reticle is close enough
to an enemy you just snap over their
chest and follow them like the Call of
Duty's so just do what I do
slap both triggers and never miss a shot
it sets your chances of the auto aim on
snapping from the target to zero because
it readjusts to them after every bullet
the game becomes a cakewalk at that
point Jesus they don't stand a chance
it's even worse when you upgrade the
damage an ammo all the way on your
weapons I mean it's a bit late now but
I'd suggest removing the auto targeting
in the sequel okay hi MA ah anyone who
knows anything about Deadpool knows he's
got a superpower called a healing factor
that makes him damn near invincible
which you wouldn't think would translate
well to a game but like x-men origins
Wolverine they did a pretty good job of
making it work do you have a certain
threshold of damage you can take before
getting a game over but your health
regenerates and so does your skin and
your suit too I guess whatever it would
look weird if he was a naked zombie guy
running around in red tatters with a
bunch of weapons I'll give that a pass
another thing that helps this game stand
out is that there's a lot of variety in
the gameplay every mission has something
new and weird to test out if that mix it
up a little
which is something games like Wolverine
Origins and Spider Man edge of time
needed a random turret section some
scenes with something funny like
inverted
controls various ultraviolent minigames
and some gimmicky maze areas go a long
way to keeping it fresh
although the joke that hey it's a video
game starts to wear out after a while
it's like every five minutes they have
to throw in some pointless caffeine or
some dialogue to mock game development
intro I get it it's a video game I am
aware
it sure does help the immersion of the
game when it keeps stopping to tell you
what you're seeing isn't real
you can stop reminding me now game [ __ ]
it was funny the first 10 times 11
through 500 got a bit tiresome sorry
getting sidetracked plot later gameplay
now Hey look they still a puzzle from
x-men origins Wolverine they actually
stole a lot of stuff from that game but
hey aspiring to be something good isn't
a bad thing as long as you don't do it
wrong the bosses are kind of standard
and even a little bit lame there's not
much of a gimmick to those beyond just
shooting them till they die which with
my trigger hammering technique is
trivial
so almost those suck actually on the
hardest difficulty the final boss is a
nightmare just because they throw so
much at you every time I walk out that
door it spawns a few dozen enemies huh
okay time to get creative ah yeah a
little bit of that and some of those
there would be a couple more of those
alright and then I'll use this and then
uh yeah yeah alright ah just like good
old Frank Castle what again
well as tough as they can be the enemies
are pretty bland it's just guys in
generic suits or clones of mr. sinister
or odd Dark Soul of enemies with rocket
launchers for some reason not sure what
the hell is with those guys they're
super out of place I think those are
like a random character model that hi
moon had from another project that got
scrapped or something on occasion there
are enemy types that resemble various
cloned x-men characters but you'll be
slashing and shooting and exploding them
too frequently to even notice their
powers or character designs look how
hectic this is if there wasn't a line of
dialogue about this enemy type
resembling gambit I probably wouldn't
even notice while blowing them to bits
on site even if they try to mix it up
here and there this game still finds
itself getting a little repetitive near
the later sections there's only so many
times you can kill the same for enemy
types before getting bored but I'll
chalk that up to budgetary constraints
this game is pretty cheaply made and
they aren't ashamed of that I really
respect that it originally shipped for
about $20 less than most games coming
out at the time it's not super
impressive technically but it's
serviceable for the amount they charged
I'm pretty satisfied with what we got
gameplay wise plus it's really neat that
they managed to get that much dialogue
into this game the combat might get
repetitive but Deadpool commentary does
not but the writing behind the game sort
of kills that aspect okay now we'll get
to the story the plot is paper-thin
Deadpool goes on a random mission to
kill some schmuck gets intercepted by a
boring random x-men bad guy teams up
with some side characters that you don't
see much goes to an island kills the bad
guy to the end it's disappointing to see
that the plot is so non-existent because
I know this game is written by the same
guy Daniel way that wrote the book for
four years just one surprise one plot
twist one introspective character moment
one interesting villain anything I know
you're better than this dude come on
what the [ __ ] are you doing Daniel
Daniel Wei wrote one of my favorite
comic arcs ever where Deadpool is hired
to assassinate Wolverine they clash over
the course of a few issues escalating
their plans of attack having Deadpool
use progressively more clever tricks to
beat him then at the end a big twist was
thrown in that Wolverine was the one who
hired Wade in secret so he could draw
his son bacon out of hiding to go keep
Deadpool from killing him there's a
great scene where Deadpool and Wolverine
talk and weigh their comparative angst
both having spent long stints as killers
and pariahs in their respective past
Deadpool grew a lot as a character here
because he showed his bitter rage at the
world for not accepting him but acting
like Wolverine was awesome despite
coming from basically the same origin
story then in the game Wolverine and
Deadpool talking it's just jokes
Wolverine says something in the Deadpool
says jokes Wolverine gets mad and
Deadpool makes another joke
what gives man why it is so hard to just
give a [ __ ] when the Arkham games exist
when ultimate spider-man and edge of
time exist it's kind of inexcusable to
have a veteran comic writer turn in such
a shallow [ __ ] script for one of
these games especially on a character
that he popularized you know I find it
funny that Deadpool zweite monologue
boxes in this game because it was
retconned a year later that this voice
in his head is an obscure Captain
America villain named madcap go figure
my Iver oh you nerds out there getting
all puffy over the fact that rogue in
the comics currently does not have the
power to fly you can officially move out
of your parents basement get a job and a
life that maybe maybe just maybe you'll
kiss a real girl you know given that new
context that kind of doesn't hold up now
huh now before we get further into this
I have to address stupid people who have
told me I'm too worried about logic it's
just a video game story doesn't matter
in games quit complaining I don't think
I'm expecting too much from video games
it's become a very influential
storytelling medium in the past 30 years
and a lot of great writing can be found
in the land of video games yeah you can
have games without story like your
minecraft your trials your Garry's Mod
your tetris is and your destinies but if
your game does have a story I think it's
fair for me to expect that it's a damn
good one if you say logic and good
writing don't matter you're saying
you're okay with mediocrity and lazy
storytelling art dies when critics stop
caring enough to complain for the right
reasons and artists are praised for
putting in minimal effort we as players
deserve better than that again if your
game has a story it better be a good one
especially in a game based on a goddamn
comic book if a book a movie a TV show
or any other type of story gets adapted
into a new format the adaptation has a
responsibility to be a good
representation and honor its source
material and if not that at least makes
something new and interesting with it
not dumb it down and make it worse
otherwise you run the risk of alienating
previous fans and misinforming new ones
which leads us to our larger point is
this game a good representation of
Deadpool [ __ ] no and now this is the way
most people think Deadpool is all the
time yeah it was written by Daniel way
well admit is the writer who got me into
reading the character during The Secret
Invasion way back in 2008 but here he
just didn't try hard enough
with an actual plot you could ask almost
any random person on the street today
how they found out about this relatively
obscure character and I can guarantee a
half of them will point to this game and
then the rest will say it was the movie
the timing of Deadpool's newfound
popularity and the release of this game
are way too close to be a coincidence so
it's safe to say that this game pretty
much brought Deadpool to the mainstream
that's cool
I respect that it took one of my
favorite characters ever and made it so
I look less like a freak in public for
my dress sense
Thanks hi moon however it created
numerous giant misconceptions about the
character and painted a really
inaccurate picture of him in the public
eye it's strange to think about how this
game contributed so much to the
character's reputation while also
actively damaging it there's the version
of Deadpool that most people know about
chimichangas me well I don't want a
fictional character in the next lever
remember chicken with Liam Neeson
remember that masturbation Jew don't
stab other things young people like hey
you know what the feel here playing
about Mexican food is in my head and
there's the one they don't care enough
to know about something I see quite
often is Deadpool being referred to as a
joke character
not unlike Squirrel Girl or one punch
man where the ideas they're really just
there to be silly overpowered and not
much else and the fan it's sad to see
that because he's a character was so
much more subtlety and nuance than that
it's like this game painted a picture of
him to just be family guy the superhero
he's just shouting swear words and dated
internet references and acting
uncharacteristically dumb the scene that
really killed my hype was when Deadpool
is so unaware of the severity of the
situation the table had to talk down to
him like a small child and say that if
he didn't defeat the bad guy his
favorite taco restaurant would be
destroyed okay Deadpool's a little
relaxed during dire situations but he's
not stupid I have no idea why but Daniel
Wei wrote him to be a complete
blithering idiot in this game despite
writing him to be really smart during
his run in the comics there's also the
fact that table can't get him to meet
him somewhere unless he makes up a story
about a buxom fangirl that will leave in
an hour it's so goddamn irritating that
Deadpool's turns into a drooling [ __ ]
for laughs in his own game the guy can
single-handedly kill every superhero in
the Marvel Universe by himself it's a
little dumb but that is actually canon
now because he hangs out with the
original universe deadpool he can trick
the hulk into giving him a blood sample
he can disarm a nuclear reactor he can
single-handedly destroy the world's
largest super-powered terrorist
he can save the multiverse three times
but he's not smart enough to walk
somewhere by himself without being duped
what the [ __ ] are you doing
he's just so nonchalant about everything
wait never seems like he actually really
gives a [ __ ] about what's happening so
it's hard to get invested if he doesn't
care why should the player care it makes
a game tease because instead of having
tension
he's just tackling away through all this
mindless violence like nothing matters
even a game like Saints Row isn't dumb
enough to have zero stakes in the story
and only do jokes actually think the
movie also suffers from a few of the
same problems as this game boring
villain ineffectual bad guys random
x-men tagging along for no reason but at
least it had Wade and Vanessa's
relationship as an emotional center in
ways seem to care what was going on he
got angry he got sad he got scared he
even had some self-esteem issues it was
minimal but it was light years better
than just nothing this game created the
version of Deadpool that I hate he's
loud obnoxious vulgar to the point of
sounding like he's trying too hard
overly violent never takes anything
seriously and worst of all he has no
heart it's just a shallow base level of
the character with all the interesting
layers underneath stripped out to
simplify it for new people this is a
Deadpool game made for people who don't
know anything about Deadpool it's a real
character has a few of these traits sure
but that's only if you don't see it for
what it is Deadpool is a tragic
character that hides his pain behind
jokes he spent his whole life getting
knocked down and turned into a villain
by people around him he struggled with
suicidal depression and self-loathing at
his core he's a character that just
wants to be loved but also wants to keep
being himself and those two things
conflict he's a bad guy that's trying to
learn how to be good and having a really
difficult time with it but every day he
makes a little progress learning to earn
people's respect
making friends being good to his family
and not letting Fame change him for the
worse
he
from being a random 90 supervillain to
being a main fixture on the Avengers and
shed a lot of tears and blood on his way
there sure he makes a few bad jokes but
I don't consider him just another
OneNote comedy character this game took
away the sad part of sad clown and just
made him an annoying jackass
I think it's frankly just as insulting
as the Baraka pool version in x-men
origins except this one pisses me off
more because they successfully got away
with it nobody complained and people
keep making mind-numbingly unfunny memes
with him now because they don't take the
time to actually understand what the
[ __ ] this character is actually about
there's a whole generation of people
around my age that only know deadpool is
the guy who cusses kill stuff yells
about chimichangas and make dumb [ __ ]
references constantly are you serious
look at the kind of products they slap
his face on that's not clever that's
just like a minions meme oh wait it is a
minions name he doesn't even like
chimichangas he just likes saying the
word over and over and this panel was
written by the same writer that came up
with the chimichanga joke in the first
place God how many [ __ ] t-shirts are
they going to slap his face on with some
unrelated dumb quote that he would never
say does Ryan Reynolds get upset that
they keep photoshopping the [ __ ] on his
pictures to sell things about his
consent ah am I crazy and are my
standards too high it might get being an
elitist
comic reading [ __ ] who likes to ruin
things for other people no one gives a
[ __ ] about nerdy [ __ ] that only two
people know about 3d artists here his
suit is black with a blue specular map
over it you're spurring a bit spurring
that mean Oh
so it means demonstrating aspects of
Asperger's oh I'll [ __ ] show you
Asperger's mr. comment man
[Music]
you know I just wasted a lot of time and
resources trying to make a point to a
single mean YouTube comment
oh [ __ ] maybe I do have Asperger's oh
really
okay well Carson already to the Deadpool
sketch so we're not doing Noah cannibal
we're not doing it anymore I wasted all
the YouTube videos cuz complaining about
atomic yeah I do this again we're
cowards done it's done you know what's
up [ __ ] [ __ ] my life
I love Deadpool I probably find him more
relatable than spider-man in terms of
personality and it sucks to see the
whole world think of him as a joke in
2009 I made a clay statue of him for a
school project in fifth grade I went as
Deadpool for Halloween when I was 10 in
2011 I had my grandpa paint a mural of
him on my wall my first tattoo was the
Deadpool logo this is my senior photo
for my yearbook I can't believe I got
away with that but what I'm saying is I
find this character a lot more
interesting and intelligently written
than people and this game give him
credit for it so if you're one of those
bandwagon fans that discovered Deadpool
through this game and sixties all jokes
and excessive violence I implore you
please go read the comic because there's
so much more to him than what you saw
here as it is I respect this game's
place in history and I know its
intention wasn't to mislead people about
Deadpool but it really missed the mark
the game part of it is fine but the
Deadpool part is way off and I want
people to stop saying the character is
an irritating [ __ ] because this version
of him is so prominent so I would not
recommend this game for Deadpool fans
but for everyone else if you want a
really cheap hack and slash game with
some fun gunplay
you you could just get an old copy of
Devil May Cry if you want to claim to be
a fan of something you need to support
it and you need to understand it you
can't walk around dressed in football
jerseys telling people you love the
sport not be able to name a single
player you can't walk around with a
Harry Potter quote tattooed on your arm
and not know which character even said
it if you think something seems
interesting go out and support it
research it become an expert with it
turn on the TV and watch some of those
football games go read the Harry Potter
books and watch the movies leave the Hot
Topic and go read some Deadpool comics
they're pretty good well you know except
for the ones written by Christopher
priest Oh suck
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I liked it before it
was cool I'm a huge hypocrite because I
were all the same dumb clothes nobody
knows how to like the same things as me
the right way everybody's enjoying the
same things as me incorrectly
I liked it before it was cool now it's
too mainstream you know I've loved this
character for a long time and now that
everyone loves him feel like they loving
him the wrong way they love him for his
body not for his beautiful soul